welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of
everything you missed in the new trailer
for Black Panther wakanda Forever both
this trailer and the Comic-Con trailer
in July were edited by the super
talented Andrew Higgly to some amazing
music and Hagley was actually kind
enough to shout me out on Twitter so I'm
gonna do my best to take his Challenge
and analyze this trailer frame by frame
for the hidden layers of meaning
everything we hear everything we see
everything everyone's wearing a couple
signings of additional black panther
suits some Clues hidden in the editing
that I'm sorry Andrew it's not your
fault but I did find them I don't know
how but I found them let's take a key
from Riri Williams and let's go oh the
trailer opens on shuri holding
t'challa's helmet during his funeral
ceremonial March all the wakandans are
wearing white which as we saw in the
2018 film is their color of mourning
Ramona holds shuri's hand to comfort her
while shuri for now remains hooded the
way her character in this trailer is
masked her earrings look like tusks or
horns maybe claws or fangs of a giant
Panther probably not real bone taken
from any living animal like the wakandan
Rhinos because shuri would never they
are Marching toward this garden region
of wakanda with a gate flanked by Stone
carvings of two people on the left
that's bashinga founder of wakanda the
first black panther to the right is a
female figure who might be his wife or
his sister either way or foreshadowing
to the Black Panther Legacy moving on to
a female figure close to the original
Black Panther and you'll notice how each
of these figures have panthers at their
feet maybe representing Bost and segment
this would be the Royal Cemetery the
necropolis may be a representation of
that green belt that t'challa referenced
in Civil War in my culture I did it's
not the end it's Marvel stepping off a
point you reach out with both hands and
bust segment they lead you into the
green world where getting around forever
meanwhile Namor paints a mural depicting
Google Khan The Feathered Serpent deity
from Mayan mythology the way the Black
Panther is an avatar of the wakandan
panther deity of Bost Namor seems to be
an avatar of kukul Khan Ryan coogler and
his team are using real world influences
to create a fictional mythology not too
perfectly adapt any actual real world
mythology but really the way boss is
inspired by the Egyptian feline deity
busted in segment taking these real
world things to create something new a
close-up of story a little later shows
that she has ceremonial white face paint
dots on her cheeks her nose and her brow
that almost exactly matched the dot
pattern on the Black Panther mask
revealed at the end of the trailer back
in that cave Neymar is painting this
mural in an aquatic cave that he must
have access to now as a mutant he can
live both underwater and on land his
skin is human colored because he is half
human born to a human sea captain though
his ears are pointed helping him paint
is this blue hand I'm assuming this is
the hand of the blue skin partner namora
they are using paint and a palette made
from a bisected shell and Morris swirls
her brush in a section in the shape of a
heart this section actually comes back
in the cutout of vibranium that River
hammers out as she forges her Iron Heart
armor now the music throughout this
trailer is an amazing
called Never Forget by sompa the great
featuring Chef 87 Tio Nason and nuanji
Samford the great is a Zambian singer
and rapper this is a tribute to a genre
called zamrock check out yesterday's
reaction for a breakdown of what that is
but the opening words of the song are
who took a fabric made that [ __ ] Classic
this is simply the Great's way of
reclaiming fashion and culture as having
roots in her Homeland but in this
context it reminds us that the Black
Panther mask and armor were a vibranium
weed physically woven and constructed by
one person and that person is shuri she
is the one who took this Fabric and made
this [ __ ] classic sure he crosses her
arms in the wakandan salute right over
left and I love her hand tattoo looking
like interconnected vibranium atoms
reminding us of her engineering insights
and infinity War the structure is
polymorphic right we had to attach each
neuron non-sequentially why didn't you
just reprogram the synopsis to work
collectively because we didn't think of
it I'm sure you did your best Neymar has
this interesting line saying only the
most broken people can be great leaders
if you think about it this has got to be
advice that he is giving either Sheree
Ramada or Okoye or one of the women of
wakanda because if he was talking to one
of his own people he'd probably be
speaking that my language not cuerta
said that he had to learn for this film
where to reveal that Neymar isn't
necessarily the villain of this movie
but rather more of an antagonist or an
anti-hero he told Empire magazine Latin
Americans are always bad guys in
Hollywood movies but now we're the
heroes or an anti-hero in this instance
and he told Entertainment Weekly maybe
the most important twist in the
character is that he's not a selfish
person he's taking care of a community
he's not an individualist he's part of a
tribe the shot from the first trailer
returns showing t'challa's Memorial
mural with wakanda lettering translating
to the panther king forever lives in us
and rests with the ancestors a wide shot
shows Neymar descending to the throne of
his kingdom the kingdom called talalo
Khan it's an Aztec afterlife for those
who die from drowning or lightning or
diseases associated with the rain deity
now articles citing this movie's
production are calling it a Mayan realm
but it's not it's an Aztec realm but
again this is all a fictional mythology
pulling from several real world sources
however note that isn't just an ocean
realm it's a realm accessed by any
water-based source which makes me
anymore and his people from Khan more
dangerous wherever you are in land
because they can get you from any body
of water deep enough to drown in one
thing that watching the kind of content
we cover here at new rockstars makes
very clear is that being the main
character is stressful enough to make
your hair fall out and for some of us
said it's already happening without the
stress of saving the planet hanging over
our heads if your hair is falling out
and you don't want that to happen you
should use keep s with keeps you can get
quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or a pharmacy
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two FDA approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy though you never have to
go to a doctor's office keeps as a
network of Expert Medical advisors
prescribers and Care Specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality whether you're looking to
prevent hair loss stimulate hair growth
or just take better care of the hair
that you have keep says you covered hair
loss stops with keeps to get 50 off your
first order go to keeps.com new
rockstars or click the link in the
description that's keps.com new
rockstars oscar-winning production
designer of the 2018 black panther film
Hannah beasler is back for the sequel
she said for these underwater shots she
took visual inspiration from Steven
Spielberg's jaws and close encounters to
the Third Kind as well as Jack Kirby
imagery and you can see both here with a
giant sharp Jawbone that forms his
throne and the way Neymar descends in
this beam of light like the blinding
light emitted by the spaceship in Close
Encounters if you look closely at that
shark Jawbone it has been carved with
Mayan figures and its teeth look like
they are made from vibranium
has its own supply of vibranium maybe a
chunk that broke off from that original
meteorite and it's likely why this human
Expedition is trying to get to them
Neymar's headpiece is a feathered
serpent matching the appearance of
cuckoo Khan costumer Ruth e Carter is
also returning and she said she had to
test these feathered outfits by
submerging them in water testing these
pieces so that it would look like a
ballet like the fish you see a National
Geographic Channel the editing of this
trailer sinks with Namor Lori and his
staff so that it looks like it is he who
is jabbing okoye's spear in the clay of
the wakanda throne room claiming it for
himself which is fitting because right
when this spear hits the trailer shifts
to rapper Chef 187's break in the song
these lyrics translate to this lyrics
referencing wearing the belt in the
phrase all kingdoms and kingdoms belong
to us now if we align state of the great
with the voice of shuri in this trailer
Chef 87 would be the voice of the
Challenger Namor cutting the bromo
demanding the belt defending his kingdom
by demanding a second Kingdom as also
belonging to him we see more shots of
the land dwellers ocean Expedition deep
sea divers and armed contracted soldiers
never a good sign these divers creepy
Shadow darting across the frame in front
of them the ship is an Enviro plus a
real world vessel that assists in Marine
Environmental Services like oil spills
but these humans are likely threatening
the people of talocon who we see
climbing aboard and raiding the ship
there's a woman who retreats to a
helicopter on the pad shooting at them
how dare this woman but I believe this
is actress Lake Bell a prolific voice
actor who voiced Natasha Romanov in
episodes of what if vanessa Fisk and
Spider-Man into the spider-verse and
Poison Ivy and HBO Max is Harley Quinn
she's a fairly big name and this film
might have something major planned for
her we see the retreat from the Golden
City up to the Jabari Mountain tribe
High land to get away from the flooding
but this shots VFX have been sneakily
edited since the July version of the
trailer because now these aircrafts
carry some heavy crates with them what
are these are they supplies vibraniums
some equipment that sure he's still
working on it could contain the
components of her new suit because we
know that a new version of the suit will
be unveiled in the snowy mountain
location surrounded by his tribesmen and
others from the Golden City mbaku tells
them about Neymar saying his people do
not call him a general or King they call
him cuckoo Khan the feather serpent God
killing him will risk Eternal War I love
how animated Winston Duke is as a
Storyteller here one also wonders how
umbaku knows this information about
Neymar to brief the others his words
make it sound like name or as the Avatar
of a deity Bears some immortality or
Untouchable status like killing them
could unleash some war between the Gods
like the fight we saw between kanchu and
Amit and Moon Knight but I don't know I
think it's more personal than that I
think mbaku knew of a secret pact
between t'challa and Neymar as fellow
Kings and avatars of deities both of
them pacifists struggling to keep peace
among the more aggressive factions of
Their Kingdoms for t'challa that was
probably in Baku but for Neymar that
would be atuma so umbaku is now warning
if you kill Neymar you're actually
opening his shark Jawbone Throne to an
even more hostile successor this could
even be why Okoye didn't do anything
about that undersea earthquake that she
referenced in Avengers endgame we again
see Neymar's underwater birth where you
can already see the little wings on his
feet but then in his adult those wings
are working overtime to Flap him into
the Golden City and later shots show
that he is floating over to the wakandan
throne room where Ramona and Riri
Williams are staring him down as he
flips up his Spirit who throw at them
this looks like a blow that's gonna be
pretty hard for a motor to evade unless
Riri or shuri might have equipped her
with some vibranium nanotech to very
quickly emit from that necklace
adornment yes I think we all really need
to see Angela Bassett in her own
vibranium suit she certainly earned one
we see more shots at the footage that
was shown at z23 French soldiers raiding
a wakanda Outreach Center in Mali trying
to plunder its vibranium but scientists
reveal themselves as covert members of
the door milage including Michaela Cole
as Anika who in the comics is a former
door milaje who leaves and forms a new
team called the midnight Angels who in
one storyline try to kill Dr Doom for
stealing wakanda vibranium she another
dorm Elijah sliced the guns using their
Spears to deflect bullets and take down
these Soldiers the d23 footage actually
ends but the door milage marching these
soldiers into the U.N to shame the
French delegate who ramonda is verbally
sparring with name or the other people
from Silicon swim one of the background
rides in Orca impressive I could
everyone stay on the inflatable pool
raft orcas neymore confronts Ramona on a
tropical beach which might be the same
Beach that we saw Nakia on with that
Mayan pyramid meaning this might be terp
belonging to Silo Khan okoye's stabs her
spear through her car one marked with
Illinois toy plates so this must be part
of her recruitment or extraction of Riri
Williams who begins her story in Chicago
a quick shot shows okoye's car someone
on a motorcycle and Riri soaring above
them both with her Iron Heart armor I
assume this is her Mark 1 armor more
shots of wakanda flooding an attack from
swallow Khan inspired by The Avengers vs
X-Men comic when Namor possessed by the
Phoenix Force actually floods wakanda
Ryan coogler told Entertainment Weekly
that the power of water and waves had a
deeper symbolic weight to this movie
with the passing of Chadwick Boseman
saying there's that idea of grief and
intense emotion feeling like it comes in
waves sometimes a wave can take you away
where you lose control of it you think
you're in control but the water can
always remind you that you are not one
brief shot shows Neymar slamming down
his Spear and if you look closely behind
him on the right there is someone in a
black panther suit fighting him or
protecting whoever Namor is trying to
stab there based on the silhouette as
this black panther jumps that looks like
the new female suit but in the shot of
the Mask maybe it's just the resolution
of the motion blur he just can't really
make out any of those signature dots on
the mask in fact it also has pronounced
silver eyebrows that don't really appear
on the female mass at the end of the
trailer so this might be a completely
different mask contributing to my theory
that we might actually see multiple
black panther suits in this movie maybe
multiple female black panther suits
Neymar uses his ankle Wings to Dart
Upward at wakanda aircraft that fire on
him zigzagging in a way that looks like
he's having across platforms like an
American Ninja Warrior and an obstacle
course mbaku must be part of this
defense we see him jumping from the
water down at Namor in the previous
trailer and in this trailer we see him
thumping his chest like a badass looks
like there will also be an aerial chase
between Riri Williams and her new
ironheart suit and some other aircraft I
think she's going to build a Mark II
armor in Sherry's live on wakanda
because there's an overhead shot showing
Riri working on that fragmented floor
pattern that is unique to the lab this
Mark II armor has Wing appendages that
pop out the back and boot mounted
thrusters similar to Tony Stark's Mark
50 armor that he used to catch up to
Spider-Man and infinity War we even see
reread an Iron Man style heads up
display close-up her head suspended in
darkness surrounded by her glowing
interface the text around her face reads
max power and there's a radar showing
her chasing someone and I love the
coloring of all this Tony's HUD was
often a pale blue and white color but
riri's is a bright red the Tuma leaps
out of a river up at aquarium on a
bridge again any body of water anywhere
poses a threat from slalocon Nakia such
as an intricate pattern of green and
blue green is the color of the wakandan
River tribe but these blue pieces of her
top are patterned to look like a Central
Lake of wakanda in a literal river that
snakes through the green land of the
country this could represent Nakia being
a river that links wakanda to the ocean
dwellers of swallow Khan there's a very
Jaws from the death shot looking up at
this wakanda vessel merch releases tell
us that this is called the Royal Sea
leopard and we know it's going to be the
setting of a major Maritime battle the
final shot of this trailer shows the New
Black Panther dropping out of a hatch
actually this is the same hatch t'challa
dropped out of in the First Act of the
2018 film but now they drop into the
snowy mountain region of the Jabari
tribe and as they land purple energy
courses up through the legs to show the
shock absorption remember this is the
technology shuri invented with her
sneakers sneaker that she is seen
wearing in promo posters for this film
this is also the same purple shock wave
that Marvel has been ending in the
letters of Marvel Studios in the opening
fanfarers of most of their recent titles
at least the ones ever since Chadwick
Boseman passed and the late latest
theatrical release added a specific shot
to the opening montages showing t'challa
doing his handshake with his little
sister who do we read this as a passing
of a torch now this is the same suit
that ended the July trailer with the
gold trimming on the Cavs the open
Panther mouths on the arms like the hand
weapons that shuri was operating in the
2018 film and now we can clearly see
this is a slender female figure that
truly does match the silhouette of
Leticia to write that plus the dots
matching her face paint does really make
us think this is shuri however you may
find the music staying familiar here
this is the same music Ryan cooglers
used for the Dora milage
so that might be a clue pointing to this
being a koi or some of the door melange
like an Aika but I don't know this music
might also just refer to the women of
wakanda in general now if you look
closely behind this figure there are a
few Jabari tribesmen but also a red
cloaked or melange who might be Okoye or
AO it's kind of hard to tell but as the
camera pans up you can see behind that
Red Cloak is a tech to up suited leg
with similar black and gold trimming so
while I think this is shuri in the suit
I really don't think she's gonna be the
only woman wearing a black panther suit
in this film this movie could present a
whole team of women who are all working
together to try to carry the legacy of
t'challa by the way I'm still a fan of
that theory that shuri could
synthetically reproduce the heart-shaped
herb and then Venture into the ancestral
plane to resurrect killmonger who is
buried at Sea I'm just still looking for
evidence for it in this footage I love
this trailer so much I cannot wait to
break down this movie when it comes out
in November you can follow me on Tick
Tock Instagram and Twitter at eavos
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]